Of course, it's nearly impossible to graph performance into
your application after it's already been built, but before
we get into good performance patterns, the first step
to insuring great performance, is being able to analyze your
performance. I want to introduce you to Colt McAnlis,
who you may remember from his excellent HTML 5 game
development course. Colt's going to show you how to analyze
your performance using the Chrome developer tools. Many developers take
way too long to start addressing performance in their applications. You see,
they get in their time lines and schedules, and they try to
get features checked in, and all these other things. And way too
late in the game, they actually realize that performance is actually a
huge issue. But you, because you're watching this video and we're having
this little private one on one talk. Are not going to fall into
that same pattern, instead your going to do two things to stay out
of it, now the first thing your going to do, is your actually
going to follow the perfmatters hash tag on your favorite social
media network, there's a lot of smart people talking a lot
about web performance. All over the net. And following this
hashtag is going to get you keyed into the exact problems on
the net and how to fix them. The second thing
you're going to do, is you're actually going to become an amazing ninja
by using Chrome developer tools to find your performance problems. Now,
we're going to walk through some of the key scenarios. And some
of the key tools that you're going to use
to address these problems. Let's take a look.